Bad Robot are planning a Star Trek
prequel An Origin story and I know what
it's about welcome to serek your Sci-Fi
TV and Movie Channel now I'm going to
say that this is Bad Robot developing
this not Paramount as many of the
articles in the last couple of weeks
have said and that they are actively
developing this but this project has not
been green lit Paramount has not signed
off on it and
really it's up in the air whether it's
ever going to happen but there is a
director there is a writer there is a
script and now Bad Robot are actively
developing that script and trying to get
Paramount to buy it but what is this
script well all the deadline was able to
report through their sources was that
this was going to be an origin story a
prequel set decades before Star Trek 4
so what does that actually mean well for
one I've been told that Paramount when
they had initial conversations with Bad
Robot over a year ago about potentially
making this prequel movie did state to
Bad Robot that it would still have to be
within the Kelvin timeline they made a
very clear distinction that between the
movies and the cinema the JJ Abrams Bad
Robot movies basically and the
television movies and the television
projects like strange the worlds Etc
still have to exist within separate un
universes there are a couple of reasons
for this one of them being a business
thing about you know potentially selling
Paramount but also there are big names
at Paramount Executives that are very
high up that already think Star Trek is
too damn complicated and if we do Star
Trek 4 which is again a big if and then
they do this movie this prequel film it
has to exist within the Calin timeline
and we will separate the two and keep
them separate Star Trek Beyond Into
Darkness Etc and this new prequel movie
on one side and hopefully a more
simplified Star Trek in the TV world
including those TV movies those are the
only goal posts that my source is
telling me Paramount set Bad Robot over
a year ago when they were having these
initial
conversations so what else do we know
other than prequel origin story decades
before well I've been able to speak to
one of my sources that does have really
really good links over at Paramount and
he's been able to see not a full version
of the script but basically a synopsis
something that has been bouncing around
for the last few months something that
tells Executives roughly what Bad Robot
are thinking and what they're thinking
is that this will be an origin of the
Enterprise that we would actually get to
see the launch of that vessel and its
maybe first couple of missions so not
Kirk and Spock at school huzzah
but there's a
problem trees I want you to get into the
comments before I carry on and I want to
see how many of you can figure out what
this problem is it took me two or three
minutes talking to the source to go hold
on wait a second to realize and then a
little bit of Googling and the source
has basically told me that the problem
that I've identified isn't really a
problem and I'll tell you why in a
minute but guys what do you think the
problem I'm thinking about is get into
the comments now I can wait if you like
the video and you like getting exclusive
news about the biggest sci-fi projects
in Hollywood don't forget to like
subscribe hit the Bell notification and
leave a comment it really helps us with
those pesky little YouTube
algorithms I'm back right I can tell you
what the problem is very simply the
Enterprise from the JJ Abrams Kelvin
timeline was built much later than the
Enterprise from the prime timeline
currently the official birth date of the
Enterprise in the Kelvin timeline is
2258 we actually see her Construction in
the film I'm going to come back to that
in a minute because how I've been told
they're going to get around this really
is kind of scuppered by that fact so in
the prime time like the Enterprise was
actually launched in
2245 now that is eight years after the
events um of the Kelvin when the Kellin
was lost at the beginning of the 2009
Star Trek movie um those events happened
in
2233 that is when those two timelines
were Divergent and we got the two
different universes first of all along
we got to see the Enterprise commanded
by Captain Robert April we have seen
that character in strange new worlds a
couple of times and I'm actually being
been told that's kind of been done on
purpose that they have dropped lots of
little hints about how cool basically
Captain April was and some even little
hints about some of the rule breaking he
got up to in a couple of the episodes of
the last season of strange new worlds
and that was done very much on purpose
between secret hideout and Bad Robot and
their collusion on this new movie
Captain Pike was the first officer for
Captain April and he then took over in
2250 and then Captain Kirk followed
later in the Kelvin timeline actually
the Enterprise was launched in 2258 and
Kirk became Captain almost immediately
when he jumped from ensen to Captain I'm
not sure that's how things work in
actual proper militaries but apparently
in the Federation it does in the insane
Kelvin timeline anyway so I pointed this
out to the source and I said look that
that can't be right because if they're
doing an origin of the Enterprise in the
celvin timeline we've already seen it we
saw her being
constructed and the answer well the
first answer was do you really think JJ
Abrams actually gives a crap about that
and I have to go yeah no he doesn't and
for the second one says they're just
going to say it was a refit they'll just
say that actually she wasn't launched in
2258 that was just when she was refit
very similar to the prime timeline when
the it's a very different Enterprise we
see in the movies than what we saw
obviously in the series because she had
a massive refit and it's actually the
Constitution to class so they would use
a similar excuse the enterprise we would
see in this prequel movie would look
similarly different to the one that we
then get in the earlier 2009
movies now I'm going to tell you what I
think of
this big
sigh JG Abrams doesn't give a crap about
Star Trek and he definitely doesn't give
a crap about trackies this film is going
to be an origin story of the Enterprise
but it's not really because he's going
to completely changeed the cannon he
wrote for the Kelvin
universe and I mean that's That's how
little he cares about Cannon he's even
willing to change the cannon he came up
with and fudge the facts a little bit to
make it look like this makes sense he
will try to get this past treis and
treis will go ah I want to swear but I
won't because this is a family show damn
it as I said we don't just see the
Enterprise like having a bit of work
done we see um the bulk of being
constructed they had the little Montage
bit and it's got like a Lego set going
together that's not a refit
so they may just say well that was a
mistake let's not worry about it too
much and move on do I actually want to
see though a origin story of the
Enterprise if I ignore all this Kelvin
timeline and Cannon desecration is this
a film I actually want to see well yeah
I kind of do if I'm honest I've told you
guys a million times before if you are a
regular s trer that I enjoy the JJ
Abrams movies they're just not Star Trek
they're good action Sci-Fi movies but
they're not Star Trek I want to see An
Origin movie of the Enterprise I want to
see her getting launched I would love to
see a as Captain in some of those
missions why not I'm not a big fan of a
prequel but in a movie you could get
away with it and you can actually
reference some of the missions that they
did reference in strange new worlds with
a little bit of care because we don't
know much about that five years when
April was the captain you could do
something which shows the launch of one
of the most beautiful Starships the
Federation ever put together without
annoying any of us trekkies that care
about Canon it would take very little
effort also though there is um a
storyline there that actually the
Federation was kind of in a cold war
with the cling on at the time and
actually The Heavy Cruiser Constitution
class was developed directly as a
response to the Klingons developing the
katinga class of heavy
warbird now I love the idea of them
doing a cold ores Style movie when
they're actually maybe finding out about
this development of a new clling on
warship and the Federation desperately
struggling to then come up with an
answer they can actually do something
that's really clever here and actually a
little bit different for Star Trek
because we could see not just the launch
of the Enterprise but the construction
because actually in the prime timeline
it doesn't just say that April commanded
the ship from launch he oversaw her
construction so that to me just makes my
imagination tingle they could actually
do a movie that maybe ends with the
launch of the Enterprise now that would
be potentially very interesting if it's
done
well now my confidence levels of a JJ
ABS movie being done well alello but
let's remember the director of this is
Toby Haynes and he is the guy that
directed the recent Andor series now
Andor for me I really enjoyed I thought
it was a really good series but it was a
bit slow um I do think they needed to
pick up the pace a little bit it was a
slow burn and at times it was painfully
slow but it was a thriller it was tense
and if you're going to make a movie that
is a tense Cold War style sci-fi
thriller he might be the guy to do it
remembering that JJ Abrams won't be
directing this he's not involved in
writing it etc etc they are just
producing it and if anything JJ AB knows
how to do it's how to make a film look
good so they can deal with all that they
can make it look pretty a few less lens
flares would be great get somebody like
Toby Haynes directing it yeah and get a
really interesting writer involved which
they've already done so this project if
Paramount decided to do it for me is
interesting and I think could be
something really interesting and a bit
different I actually think the Star Trek
franchise needs something a bit
different it needs a bit of a kick up
the ass and a tense Cold War style you
know Espionage Etc blah blah blah a film
that actually builds up to that big
launch and then you know it'll have to
fly off and do something at the end of
the movie you know to you know make a
point of the film but that could be
really really cool the basically the
start of the third act would be the
launch of the Enterprise that kind of
thing but guys get into the comments and
tell me what you think is this a movie
that interests you as much as it
interests me I the end of the day any
good story can be done badly and any bad
story can be done really really well but
does this potential Star Trek movie have
at least the building blocks of
something interesting get into the
comments and tell me what you think but
more importantly do you actually think
it will ever happen if I put my hand on
my heart I don't think it will I don't
think Paramount want to do this right
now I think Bad Robot have leaked this
trying to get a little bit of momentum
behind the project and I actually don't
think it's going to happen
but the people in charge at Paramount
today will not be the people in charge
at Paramount in about 12 to 18 months
there is a sale coming through new
owners will come in and I suspect a new
philosophy a new hierarchy of managers
Etc and that might be enough to breathe
a second life into this movie
finally get into the comments Zone and
tell me if it was a choice between this
idea of this prequel the birth of the
Enterprise movie and a straight up Star
Trek 4 with Chris Pine Etc which would
you prefer I think I prefer the prequel
movie but get into the comments and tell
me what you think because this is a
community it's not just about what I
think it's about what you think
to if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really help ENT and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to
patreon.com where most of our new videos
do Premiere first and you get to see
them without the adverts you lucky lucky
bunnies also go to
c.co which is where we do articles for
most of our videos and it's that
dedicated website where we try to add a
little bit more information for you to
digest go check it out as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
well all deadline was able to report
through their sources with this
in the Kelvin timeline actually the
Enterprise was launched in 2258 and Kirk
became Captain almost immediately when
he jumped from Epson to when he jumped
from
[Music]
eps